General Assembly of the United Nations
the body representing all the UN member
states has a new president - Gianni
Mohammed Banda of Nigeria this is the
start of the 74th session and as is
tradition it gets underway at ambassador
level one week before the leaders of all
the countries arrive to take their seats
this is when this part of New York
becomes the setting for diplomacy's most
important annual gathering one that
shuts down part of the city and pushes
traffic elsewhere to a standstill
it has gone up extraordinarily fast in
the last couple of days however the
mayor of New York's Commissioner for
International Affairs welcomes the
annual event which brings in a windfall
in restaurant and hotel bookings and the
reality is the UN brings about three
point six nine billion dollars to the
New York City economy annually it also
employs about 16,000 New Yorkers world
leaders arrive here in the next week but
as ever it's too early at this stage to
say which issues will dominate the
meeting on Monday the UN
secretary-general will chair a climate
change summit he's asked leaders to come
up with an action plan rather than just
speeches and the issue of tensions
between Iran and the u.s. is likely to
be center stage although a meeting
between President Trump and President
rouhani now looks much less likely James
BAE's al Jazeera at the United Nations